Prof: We're now at the
stage where we're considering
the implications of uncertainty,
so I hope that the subtlety,
and surprise element of the
class,
will gradually pick up without
increasing the difficulty.
The complexity will pick up a
little bit, but not the
difficulty.
It's just you'll have to keep a
few more things in your head,
but the mathematics isn't any
harder.
So we ended last time talking
about default and inferring
default probabilities,
and so I just want to finish
off that discussion.
So suppose that at any stage of
the tree, you know,
lots of things can happen in
the world.
We're always going to model the
uncertainty in the future by a
tree with different things
happening,
and at each of these nodes
people are going to have a
discount rate.
So maybe it'll be r equals 20
percent,
and here r could equal 15
percent, something like that,
and we want to add to this the
possibility that there's
default.
So if we add the possibility of
default, and these things keep
going and maybe there are
payoffs at the end or payoffs
along the way.
If at any point in the tree
like this one we add a new
possibility,
which is the default
possibility, so this happens--
by the way, when do people
default?
They never default before they
have to make a payment.
So when do they default,
exactly when they're supposed
to make a payment.
So suppose that this guy is
going to default here when he's
going to make a payment.
At every possible scenario he
would default there.
So we've got a very simple
model of default,
so not a very realistic one
where the guy defaults in all of
these following scenarios.
So something's just bad.
Once he's gotten here you know
that he's not going to make the
payment the next period.
We further assume that not only
does he default there,
but he defaults on everything
thereafter.
So the payoff is just going to
be 0 here.
So this is going to
be--originally we had
probabilities p_1,
p_2,
p_3,
let's say for the
probabilities,
now we're going to have
probabilities d for default and
then 1 - d times all of these,
right?
So essentially what have we
done?
We've simply replaced in our
calculation of payoffs and
present values,
we've simply replaced these
possibilities with probability
p_1,
p_2,
p_3.
We added another possibility,
but the payoffs are 0 here.
Nothing's going to happen from
then on except 0,
and we said that happened with
probability d,
which means presumably,
all of these have to be scaled
down by that so they still add
up to 1.
So essentially the point I'm
trying to make is that default
that leads to 0 payoffs
thereafter is just like
discounting more.
Why is that?
Because whatever calculation
you did for the value here of
what the bond could possibly be
worth there is--
it's all the same numbers as
there were before except we've
multiplied it by 1 - d,
so it's the same thing.
So instead of going 1 over 1 r
times future payoffs,
that's no default value,
so that times future payoffs.
Now we've got default value
under this special kind of
default is going to be 1 - d
times 1 over 1 r times the same
future payoffs.
I could rewrite 1 - d as 1 over
1 s or something,
and so then I really have just
1 over 1 r times 1 over 1 s.
So that's just 1 over (1 r s r
s).
So that's going to equal 1 over
(1 r s r s) times future values.
So the effect of this special
kind of default--we just get 0
thereafter.
The guy decides after this
payment, "I'm not going to
make any more payments.
I'm defaulting from then
on."
That's the same thing when
valuing the future payoffs,
it's the same thing as instead
of discounting by r,
discounting by r s with a
little bit r times s.
If r and s are small numbers
this [r times s]
is probably quite a small
number.
So default probabilities get
mapped into spreads they're
called.
They way to evaluate it is just
you just multiply it by 1 - d,
which is the same thing as
discounting by a higher number,
and that higher number is
almost the same.
It's very close to r d,
as a matter of fact,
because 1 - d is 1 over 1 s.
If d is very small s is going
to be very close to d as well.
So what's the implication of
this?
The implication of this in a
special case again where we just
have no uncertainty,
except we have default.
So here there could be
d_1,
1 - d_1 and here
there could be probability of
default 2 and 1 - d_2,
probability of default 3,1 -
d_3,
and we've got interest rates
r_0--
so this will be i_0,
i^(F)_1,
i^(F)_2.
So if you knew what the
interest rate was going to be
today,
you knew what the interest rate
was going to be tomorrow,
was going to be the day after
tomorrow,
there's no uncertainty about
interest rates,
they're perfectly
anticipatable,
but you know that there's a
probability of default each
time.
So in stage 1 this guy might
default before making his
payment here,
which case you're just going to
get 0.
In stage 2 he might default
instead of making his payment,
won't pay the coupon,
he'll just default,
or in year 3 he might default.
So what's the implication of
what we just said?
You can evaluate this bond,
the payoffs of the bond,
so let's say it pays a coupon,
C, C 100 C.
All right, the way you would
evaluate that without default is
you would just take the value of
the coupon,
the present value would have
been--you would have done it
recursively.
You would have gotten
P_3 = 100 C.
Then you would have said
P_2,
you would have gone in your
computer--
you would have said
P_2 is 1 over (1
i^(F)_2) times 100 C.
So the value here is the 100 C
discounted by that forward rate,
then P_1 would have
been (C P_2) divided
by (1 i^(F)_1).
So you take the value here
times that,
so this is case there's no
default,
and P_0 would have
been (C P_1) over (1
i^(F)_0).
So that's how you would have
done it by backward induction.
But now that you know there's a
chance that there's default you
have to not multiply by 1
i^(F)_2.
You have to multiply all these
things by the probability of
default.
So you'd have to multiply this
by, if we change colors,
by 1 - d.
You have to multiply this by 1
- d_2,
and you'd have to multiply this
by (1 - d_1) times (1
- d_2),
and this by 1 -,
sorry this would be 1 -
d_3.
This is (1 - d_3)
times d_2,
and this is (1 - d_1)
times (1 - d_2) times
(1 - d_3).
So this value would be the old
value you got here multiplied by
1 - d_3,
multiplied by this one minus
d_3.
This value is what you would
have gotten here,
but you've already scaled it
down, so multiplied by 1 -
d_2 and this is 1 -
d_1.
So what's the upshot?
So that gives you the price
with default.
Student: Professor?
Prof: Yep?
Student: When you're
doing the backwards induction
should you be tacking on like
that or should we just take one
at a time.
So P_0 should be
multiplied by all 3,
or isn't it that you're taking
whatever you get as
P_1 as given and just
multiply by...
Prof: Well,
I could have done it two ways.
I could have written--so what
you're suggesting is a better
way would have been to say
P_2,
the default bond P_2
is going to be (1 -
d_3) times
P_3,
which is also equal to
P_3 because there's no
default after here.
The world just ends.
Then P_1 is equal to
(1 - d_2) times
P_2,
but that P_2,
remember, is already (1 -
d_3) times
P_3.
And then P_0 is going
to be (1 - d_1) times
(1 - d_2) times
P_1,
but that's equal to (1 -
d_1) times (1 -
d_2( times
P_1,
which is (1 - d_3)
times P_3,
right?
So all right,
if you go from here to here the
value here's 100 C,
so if P_3 is just 100
C let's leave it as 100 C.
That's if the guy actually pays.
So the present value would just
be--oh, then you have to divide
all this by 1 i_2.
Sorry, this is 1
i^(F)_2.
Oh, I'm making a mess of this.
So usually you'll go back from
here to here by discounting by
the interest rate,
but now we're going to have to
also multiply by the probability
that you default to go back
here.
So we get a lower number.
P_2 is not just (100
C) divided by (1 i^(F)),
that's the discounting,
you also have to multiply by
the probability of default.
Then when you go back one
period further you have to
discount again.
So I should have divided this
by 1 i^(F)_1,
you have to discount it,
and also you have to multiply
by the probability of default.
But the thing you're bringing
backwards is P_2,
which has already taken into
account the probability of
default the next time.
Then when you go back one step
further you have to do the whole
thing again divided by 1
i^(F)_0.
Student: You shouldn't
have a 1 - d_2 in
there as well,
shouldn't you just be
discounting by 1 - d_1
and 0?
Prof: This is
P_1 not P_2.
Student: You've already
discounted by 1 - d_2.
Prof: No,
but I'm switching the Ps on
you.
When we go from here the value
here we just calculated was
going to be P_2,
so here the value of
P_1 taking into
account default is (1 -
d_2) times
P_2,
which already takes into
account the default next time,
times P_2 discounted
by the interest rate here.
So I've got the 1 -
d_2 here.
Now, when I discount back to
here you're saying,
"How come the
d_2's showing up any
more because I'm just at
d_1,
that's your question, right?
So it doesn't show up.
It's just P_0 is 1 -
d_1--
oh, you're asking this,
you're right,
(1 - d_1)--you were
right--
times P_1 divided by
(1 i^(F)_0).
That's right,
but if I plug in for
P_1,
P_1 already
had--that's where the
d_2 came from,
so P_1's got the
d_2 in it.
So it's (1 - d_1)
times (1 - d_2) times
P_2,
and then P_2 had a
P_3 in it.
So I've got all the defaults in
it.
Are you with me now?
So, sorry about that,
so you were right,
I said it wrong.
So, but this isn't the point.
This was supposed to be obvious.
I didn't even think about it.
The next step is the thing
that's not obvious.
Here are the potential cash
flows.
You're discounting them by the
interest rate.
You also have to discount it
again by the fact that the guy
might not actually pay you.
So that gives you a lower
present value.
Yellow P_2 is less
than the no default white
P_2.
When you discount again you're
discounting the yellow
P_2 by the interest
rate here and also the fact that
the guy might not pay.
So you have to multiply by 1 -
d_2 and also the fact
that he might not pay,
the forward rate,
and you keep moving that
backwards.
So that was supposed to be
obvious even though I made it
sound complicated.
What's slightly subtler is just
saying the same thing backwards
which is, suppose I knew all
these forward rates.
Suppose I had a bunch of bonds,
suppose I had American bonds,
coupon bonds.
So the American coupon bonds
are going to pay,
you know, the 1-year pays a
coupon C_1 and has a
face of 100 and has a price
Pi_1.
The 2-year American bond has a
coupon C_2,
a face of 100,
and a price of Pi_2.
And let's say the 5-year has
something, C_5,
a face of 100 and a price
Pi_5.
Now from that we know that we
can deduce what all the forwards
are.
We did that in the first class.
So now suppose at the same time
we have Argentina.
Many Argentine sovereign bonds
promise payments in dollars,
by the way, they're trying to
trade them internationally.
So let's say we also have the
Argentina bonds
C-hat_1,
100, Pi-hat_1,
that's the 1-year,
down to the 5-year which is the
Argentina C-hat_5,
100 and Pi-hat_5,
its price.
Now, let's suppose that
Argentina could default whereas
America can't.
So it's quite likely that
Pi-hat_1 will be less
than the American Pi_1
and Pi-hat_5 is going
to be less than the American
Pi_5,
because all these bonds might
default.
So if the coupons were the
same, if C-hat_1 was
the same as C_1 and
C-hat_5 was the same
as C_5 the fact that
Argentina could default
obviously would mean its bonds
would trade less for the
American ones.
So the question is can you
figure out the default
probabilities very quickly in
Argentina without having to do a
lot of complicated calculations,
and the answer is yes.
And why is that?
Because you could take this
data and you could say--so we
could just erase this here.
We could say,
assuming no default,
we could explain these prices
by finding,
just like we did the America,
the Argentine forwards,
1 i-hat_0,
1 i-hat^(F)_1 and 1
i-hat^(F)_4.
So these are the Argentine
forwards.
Now, these forwards would be
much bigger than the American
forwards.
Why is that?
Because the prices in Argentina
are so much lower.
If you're assuming there is no
default, assuming no default,
contrary to fact,
how could you explain all these
very low prices?
Well, you must think that in
Argentina they've got very high
interest rates and very high
forwards,
so they're discounting more and
that's why they've got lower
prices.
And we know how to get those
forwards assuming there was no
default.
So the trick,
I'm merely pointing out now,
is that if we now go back and
say, ah ha,
Argentina doesn't have
different forwards because
anyone in Argentina--
the bonds are denominated in
dollars precisely so that people
can be crossover investors.
An American can put his money
in Argentina.
An Argentine can put his money
in America, so you can move your
money to either place.
So it must be that the forward
rates can't be different.
If you knew for sure you were
going to get paid in Argentina
you'd have to have the same
forward rates in America.
So the reason these forward
rates are higher is because
there's a chance of default.
So what is the chance of
default?
So I claim the chance of
default is, and I was
supposedly--you're supposed to
realize this now.
If I'd been clearer before you
would see where I'm going.
The chance of default is
incredibly simple to find out.
So it's 1 - d_t =
what?
Student:
>
Prof: But in terms of
forwards is what?
It's not Pi--this Pi,
this isn't the 0 price.
This is the big price of the
bonds.
So it's not Pi-hat_t
over Pi_t.
What is it though?
Student: The ratio of
forwards?
Student: Pi_t
- >
Prof: This is going to
be a bigger number than that,
and in fact that ratio is the
default probability.
So this is assuming,
remember, that if the Argentine
bond defaults at this period,
say, it's never going to pay
anything after that.
You're going to get 0 pay off
and all the other Argentine
bonds will also default.
I claim that this [note:
meaning, (1 - d_t =
(1 i^(F)_t-1) over (1
i-hat^(F)_t-1)) ]
is going to be the easy way of
getting the default probability.
And so the differences in the
forwards is just explained by
the default probabilities and so
the extra Argentine interest,
if this [the denominator]
is a higher number than that
[the numerator],
1 - d is approximately 1 over
(1 d),
and so it's basically if all
the numbers i and d are small
then i-hat^(F)_t - 1
is approximately i^(F)_t -
1,
the American one,
plus this default rate in
Argentina.
So I should probably have a hat
because I'm referring to
Argentina with the hat.
So why is that true.
I just argued it.
How could that possibly be true?
So you see what I'm claiming
that you have now a very simple
algorithm for finding out,
inferring what Argentina
default rates are.
Again, I'm making a special
assumption that when Argentina
defaults you get nothing.
That really isn't the case.
There's some huge convention
that happens and all the
countries get together they
defaulted on.
They've got some big meeting,
and someone like Brady invents
some idea where they'll owe less
and they will be a writing down
of principal,
by the way.
So whenever this happens there
is recovery after a writing down
of principal.
So what all the countries do is
they say, "Okay,
we know that you can't pay all
that you owe us.
We'll settle for half of it.
We'll write down the principal
and we'll hold you to that half,
or to a third of it.
So this is one of the things we
curiously haven't done in
America where all these
homeowners can't pay and we
don't write down their
principal.
We just throw them out of their
houses.
But anyway, let's say you wrote
the principal down to 0 in that
special case.
You could easily infer from the
price of the Argentine bonds
what the default probabilities
were, and by this formula.
And so the question is,
why is that true?
We know how to calculate the
forwards in America given the
American data.
That's was one of the first
things we did in class.
We said that every American
company in the whole country,
financial company,
is doing that.
Everybody has those forwards
calculated.
Now, if you're given the
Argentine data,
which is, after all,
just coupons and the prices of
the bonds,
you could find Argentine
forwards assuming there's no
default.
But there is default,
so it must be that they have
access to the American interest
rates in forwards,
but the Argentine bond might
default.
Do you see what we did when we
did this calculation?
The difference between the
backward induction in America
from here to here was just
discounting by the American
forward--
to go to Argentina we had to
discount by the American forward
and multiply by 1 - d,
so discounting it again.
So all I'm saying is that in
the U.S.
when we went backwards we just
discounted by this thing.
In Argentina when you go
backwards you have to discount
by this thing,
so those things have to be the
same.
So the Argentinian discount is
like taking the--
I hope I haven't got the
thing--so the American forwards
are going to be less than the
Argentine forwards.
It's going to be like that.
So that's it.
There's nothing else to show
except that whenever you're
going backwards here you're
discounting--
remember, you're discounting by
the interest rate times the
probability that you're actually
going to pay off,
so that's what it is in
Argentina.
Hang on.
I hope I haven't inverted one
of these, yeah,
exactly.
So if you write 1 - d times the
American thing in the
denominator,
so as I said,
to do the discounting in
Argentina at every step from
going back from here to here
what did we do in Argentina?
We simply took 1 - d-hat,
that was the default
rate--hat--in Argentina,
and discounted it at the
American forward.
So that's what I did here.
So if I take 1 - d-hat,
this is multiplied by 1,
so I take 1 - d-hat^(
)multiplied by 1 over this.
I just get one over the
Argentine discount,
and that's how we
calculated--that's how we went
backwards with our recursion
just taking the interest rate,
the discount 1 over (1 i) times
(1 - d) and that's how we
discounted going backwards.
And so therefore in Argentina
if you're forgetting that
there's default and you're just
thinking you have to discount at
the right rate and you're
getting this discount you're
getting this number,
but in reality you should have
been taking this divided by
that.
So therefore figuring out this
and knowing that tells you what
this has to be.
So it's extremely simple to
deduce what the market thinks
Argentinian default
probabilities are year by year
if you make the added assumption
that once they default they
default completely.
And if you think you're only
going to get a little bit back,
well then the calculation won't
change that much.
Yeah?
Student: Can we also do
it by using the price of 0s?
Prof: Yeah,
so you could also do it by
using the price of 0s,
but to me the best thing is,
the easiest thing is using the
forwards,
but you can also do it by 0s.
So that's all I wanted to say.
As I said, the one last thing
to say is that if these numbers
are all small then 1 over 1 -
d--or, 1 - d is approximately
equal to 1 over (1 d).
If d is very small those are
practically the same things.
Then if you multiply 1 over (1
d) by 1 over (1 i) it's almost 1
over (1 d i),
so it's almost this thing.
It's not quite true,
literally true,
but it's very close to say that
the gap between Argentinian
forwards and American forwards
is just the default probability
in Argentina,
and that reason is why it's
called a default spread.
You just add some spread to the
interest rate.
You can guess by the spread
what the probability of default
is.
If it's 8 percent interest
there and 3 percent interest
here somebody must think the
probability of default is 5
percent there.
That's it.
So let's now move to a tree
where you have to make
decisions.
So I'm going to now describe
the method of backward induction
which occurs over and over and
over again,
and we've used it a couple of
times,
but not in its subtlest form,
so backward induction.
Now, who first invested the
idea of backward induction?
Well, the first person who
spelled it out formally was
Zermelo in 1910,
I think, that's within a couple
of years,
a famous mathematician,
Fraenkel-Zermelo Axioms.
And he proved that chess--that
there's an optimal strategy in
chess by backward induction.
So, for example,
let's take a game.
We always are on a tree,
but now we're going to use a
slightly extended definition of
a tree.
A tree is going to look like
this.
So it's a root,
a finite number of branches
from every--I don't want to
formally define a tree.
You know what it sort of looks
like, and there's no reason why
the number of branches has to be
two or even has to be the same
from every point.
But the reason we're going to
extend it is,
the node is going to be
described by who moves.
So let's say white is moving
here and black is moving here.
Now, let's say the outcomes are
a win for white,
a win for black,
a draw, or a draw.
So the question is,
so it's a two-move chess game,
white moves first up or down,
and then after white moves
black moves up or down and then
the game ends.
And depending on where,
position you reach either it's
a win for white,
a win for black,
or a draw.
So what should white do?
Assuming that black is a smart
player what should she do?
So what did Zermelo do?
He said not only there is an
optimal strategy,
but you know what the outcome
should be with rational players.
So Zermelo said if white goes
up then black is clearly going
to go down and win the game.
So white ought to be thinking
here, if I go up,
the game, although it won't end
for another period,
it's already lost.
So the value of the game is
already 0.
So this method of backward
induction attaches the value.
Here we have values at the end,
and so to figure out what the
right thing to do is by backward
induction you can propagate the
values backwards.
If black makes the right choice
here the payoff is black gets
the negative of white,
so the right choices here are
black could get negative 1 or
could get 0,
so black clearly wants to get 0.
So black could win the game by
moving down, so black surely
will move down.
So I should think of the game
as already lost here and pretend
that I had a shorter tree with
the final valuation of zero at
this node.
Similarly, if white goes down
it doesn't matter what black
does the game is going to be
drawn.
So white should think to
himself the game is already a
draw if I go down.
And now white has an easy
choice, do I want to move to a
loss or do I want to move a
draw.
So I could just pick a move for
black here.
Clearly white is going to go
down and therefore with correct
play the game is a draw.
So by backward induction you
figure out the correct play.
Now, why is this surprising?
Because chess has an incredibly
big tree, not an infinite tree,
there are all these rules that
keep it finite.
If you reach to the same
position three times it's
considered a draw.
If you make something like 50
moves in a row without a pawn
moving it's a draw.
Whatever those rules are--I
used to play chess quite a bit.
I've even forgotten.
But whatever those rules are
they're designed to make the
game finite, so the tree is
finite.
And so it's impossible to see
the whole tree,
and how should you know what to
do at the beginning?
Well, you don't know what to do
at the beginning until you know
what black's going to do
afterwards, and so what could
happen later in the tree.
But if you were fast enough to
put the whole thing on a
computer you could figure out
what to do at the beginning,
because your best move at the
beginning depends on what you
think black is going to do next,
which depends on what he thinks
you're going to do after that,
which depends on what you think
he'll do after that.
But if the tree ends you can
always go backward from the end
to the beginning and figure out
what to do at the very
beginning.
So this is a familiar argument
to all of you,
I think.
It was a beautiful argument in
chess in 1910 and then it was
anticipated--I mean,
in mathematics in 1910.
The chess players,
of course, all knew about it,
so Steinitz who was a world
champion from when to when,
something like 1870 or so to,
or 1880 let's say to let's see,
19,21, to 1894.
I think he was world champion
from then to there.
Lasker became the champion then.
So he wrote a bunch of books
and stuff in which he said
there's a backward induction
value to chess,
but since we can't figure that
out on general principles you
can tell by looking at the
configuration of pieces what the
right possible move is,
and so you can have positional
values,
so I'll do that,
and then you can have the
backward induction values.
So for instance a positional
value might tell you that having
doubled pawns is a bad thing,
having control of the center's
a good thing and you add up all
those pluses and minuses and you
get these positional values.
And so he said if you've got
the right positional algorithm,
right positional understanding,
your positional sense of what
to do,
you only need to analyze one
move deep.
You can figure out what the
best position's going to be and
move that way,
and if you really understand
the game properly that
positional thinking,
that strategic thinking,
so it's called strategic
thinking,
is going to give you the same
decision as the exhaustive
analysis of all the
possibilities which was tactical
thinking,
so the two should amount to the
same thing.
Now, in fact,
people can't do the full
tactical thing and also they
don't have the full strategic
understanding either,
so they kind of mix strategy
and tactics and that's what
makes the game interesting.
So no one has ever written
this, but I'm sure there's an
interesting study to be made
about what games are interesting
and they must be the kinds of
games where there's always a
mixture of strategy and tactics.
In game theory,
as we describe it in economics,
there's no such thing as
strategy.
All this is out.
It's all just backward
induction, which is what I'm
teaching you.
So the way computers play
chess, incidentally,
is--and the guy who invented
this is Shannon,
so he's a famous professor of
information systems,
so an engineering professor.
So he said, well,
you can't look at the whole
tree which is too long in chess,
so what you should do--so all
this extends way further.
Maybe you can only look two
moves deep.
So what Shannon recommended is
look as far as you can put in
your computer,
apply some positional thinking
to evaluate these positions at
the pseudo end of the tree.
So it's really not a win for
white.
Let's just pretend White's so
far ahead that we'll call it a
win, and a loss,
and a draw, and a draw.
That's just by looking at
positional values.
And then having assigned those
terminal nodes values,
now by backward induction you
can figure out what the value is
here and exactly what the right
first move to make is.
And after white's move black
will come here,
black can now look two moves
deep, so black's going to look
from here all the way down here.
He's going to do his positional
evaluator to these nodes and try
and figure out what they're
worth and then do backward
induction to figure out what his
right move is.
Anyway, that's basically the
idea of all chess algorithms,
and then they've gotten refined
by saying--wait a minute,
there are lots of refinements.
So I used to very interested in
this.
I don't think I'll talk more
about it unless anyone wants to
ask me something.
So there's the origin of
backward induction,
Zermelo's proof and it's
obviously a big deal in chess
and the chess players all knew
about it before Zermelo,
but they didn't write anything
down as formal as Zermelo.
So how does this apply to
everything we do in economics?
Well, I want to give a series
of examples culminating in
market examples,
but starting off a little far
from life.
So the first one I want to give
is the red and the black.
So these are just two games.
This is the first one I
invented ten years ago,
but I don't think
they're--anyway,
I think they aren't that
original.
I thought they were when I
invented them.
But anyway, so the red and the
black works like this.
There's a deck of cards,
52 cards, a deck of 52 cards,
so half of them are--26 red,
right, and 26 black,
which is all I care about the
cards.
And someone offers you a game
and they say,
okay, the deck is upside down,
they've been shuffled,
you can turn over a card and if
it's black I'll pay you 1
dollar.
If it's red you have to pay me
1 dollar.
So I'm offering you this chance
to play this game and of course
you can quit whenever you want
to.
I can't keep forcing you to
play, so anytime you want to you
can quit.
So that's the game,
can stop whenever you want.
And once you draw the card you
throw it away.
And so all these examples are
going to be examples of stopping
games and you'll see in
economics that when you prepay
on a mortgage or when you call a
bond you're stopping the thing,
the contract's ending.
Life is going on,
but that contract is ending,
so want to know,
when's the right time to take
an action like that?
So red and black is a simple
game like that where you turn
over a card.
If it's black,
you're in the black you win 1
dollar.
If it's red you lose 1 dollar
and you can stop whenever you
want.
So you have an option,
so call this an option,
and most people totally
underestimate the value of
options.
So let's just figure out how to
figure out the optimal thing to
do.
What would you do in this game?
Would you play if I gave you
the chance to play?
I think I did this on the very
first day.
Yes, you're about to say
something?
Your hand twitched.
Student: I was going to
say we have deceasing marginal
utility as well,
so assuming we have
>
you wouldn't play the game
because you would derive less
utility from winning 1 dollar
than you would
>
in magnitude that the loss
Prof: So I'm going to
now disagree with what you said,
but it's very interesting what
he said.
He said, look,
if you draw a card at the
beginning it's 50/50 whether
you're going to win or not.
If you win you get 1 dollar.
If you lose you lose 1 dollar,
50/50 chance.
If you're a little bit afraid,
if a 1 dollar loss is more
important to you than a 1 dollar
gain right away it's not very
good odds,
I mean, it's barely even,
and if you're a little bit risk
averse and it's barely even you
shouldn't play.
But now, is it really barely
even, this game?
Yep.
Student: Well,
I mean, I think you should play
because even if you get the
first 26 red at that point just
go to the end and you haven't
lost anything except the time
you've spent playing the game.
You might as well play on the
off chance that you'll get some
blacks ones first.
Prof: Right,
so you can't possibly lose if
you play this right.
You can always go to the very
end of the deck.
We're ignoring a good point.
We're ignoring your utility of
time, so you can always go to
the end of the deck and assure
yourself of 0.
So this is actually a pretty
valuable option to be able to
stop like he says.
If the first one's black you
could stop and then you've won 1
dollar.
If a whole bunch of them are
red and you lose,
well, you can always go to the
end of the deck and get zero.
So you're never going to lose
and you have a chance of
winning.
So obviously you should play.
Even if you are risk averse you
should play, but now the
question is can we tell exactly.
Suppose you're risk neutral?
How many dollars do you expect
to win would you guess?
Yep?
Student: 0.
Prof: You'd expect to
get 0.
Now he just made an argument
that you should expect more than
0, because for instance he said
take this strategy.
Pick a card.
If it's black you win 1 dollar,
quit.
You're 1 dollar ahead.
So at 50 percent of the time
you're plus 1 dollar.
If it's red the first time just
close your eyes and play to the
end of the game and you're going
to get 0 because you're going to
win 26 times and lose 26 times.
So that's equal to .5.
So there's one strategy that
gets you 50 cents on average.
You can't lose and half the
time you'll get 1 dollar,
but that may not be the best
strategy.
Student: You can play a
bunch of times and at worst
you'll break even and at best
you could get all 26 black.
Prof: Right.
So he's saying this isn't
ambitious enough.
This surely gets a half a
dollar, but you could do much
better.
Like, let's just wait.
The first time suppose you get
1 dollar.
Suppose you get black the first
time, so that gives you 1
dollar.
Now, the trouble is the deck is
starting to turn against you.
Now it's 25 blacks and 26 reds.
So what would you do then?
Student: I'd stop.
Prof: You'd stop or keep
going?
Well, the deck is against you,
so now your very next draw is
unfavorable.
And, by the way,
playing to the end of the deck
is going to lose you 1 dollar
because there are 25 black and
26 red,
so this argument that if you
just play to the end of the deck
you'll break even it's not true
after you've already taken a
black one out,
so you could lose it.
From then on you're starting to
run a little bit of a risk.
So we're ignoring risk aversion.
We're just caring about
expected dollars.
The fact is the deck is against
you, so should you play or not?
And so first reaction is hell
no, the deck's against me.
Why should I draw another card?
But you still have the option
of going to the end of the deck,
so the most you could lose is 1
dollar if you went all the way
to the end of the deck,
and who knows,
maybe you'll get a run of more
black cards in the beginning and
make a lot more than 1 dollar.
So you should choose another
card.
In which case if you get black
again--
if you got red on the next card
you'd be breaking even,
but now it's 25/25 and by the
previous argument it's obvious
you should pick another one
because the worst you can do is
break even from then.
But what if you got two blacks
in a row?
Well, now the deck is way
against you.
It's 26 red and 24 black,
so now you've only got a 48
percent chance of drawing a
black one the next time.
The deck is going further
against you.
Should you really draw another
card?
It's more likely to be red.
Well, the answer is yes.
And suppose you got a black one
again, meaning you're three up,
and now the deck is 26/23.
Sorry, I went the other way,
26 red, 23 black.
It's getting further and
further against you.
Should you draw another card?
Well, what you've got is you've
got a bad deck working against
you, but you've got this option
working in favor of you.
So the question is just how
valuable is the option.
And like I said,
people always underestimate the
value of options.
And so--okay, go ahead.
Student: Don't you want
to play until your
lose-condition is either
balanced out or worse than your
win condition?
Prof: Yes,
but what is that condition?
Student: Thirteen blacks
>
Prof: If you got ten
blacks in a row you would keep
drawing blacks,
is that what you were saying?
Student: Well,
I mean, at that point if you
assume that that's all
>
, assuming that you pick
another red and then play out
the end of the game you could
lose, it would be...
Prof: Thirteen more.
So you're saying you want to
keep drawing blacks until if you
play to the end of the deck you
would lose as much as you'd won
up until that point.
So you want to never run the
risk of losing more.
But you see,
that strategy would get you to
quit after the first one.
After the first black if you
ran to the end of the--your
strategy doesn't make sense.
By going to the end of the deck
you're always going to undo
everything you've won until that
point,
because you'll be zero no
matter what if you go to the end
of the deck.
Yep?
Student: Shouldn't you
quit whenever you have 1 dollar,
because say if you have more
black cards than red cards then
the number of black cards left
in the...
Prof: Deck is less...
Student: Is lower than
the number of red cards left in
the deck, so you should quit
whenever you have 1 dollar.
Prof: No.
So he's saying just the
commonsensical thing.
After you draw one black card
he would quit because now the
deck is against you.
It's 25 red [correction:
26 red]
and only 25 black.
The deck's against you.
Why go on and play against an
unfavorable deck?
You've got your dollar,
be satisfied and quit.
That's his recommendation,
but that's wrong and it's
because you're doing what
everybody does.
You underestimate the option.
The option is incredibly
valuable here and now I just
want to show how to compute what
your optimal strategy is,
and I think you'll be
surprised.
You should keep drawing,
not three times--if you got a
fourth black card,
so you've already made 4
dollars.
It's a sunk cost.
You've got this horrible deck.
It's 26,22.
Should you keep playing?
Yes you should.
Yes you can.
If you get a fifth black card
in a row you're up 5 dollars.
The deck is horribly against
you.
Should you keep playing?
Yes you should.
So anyway, it's really
shocking, I think.
So now let's just see how to
compute this out so that we
don't have to argue about it.
It's just a little bit of
mathematics and you just see how
surprising this calculation is.
So how would you do it?
Well, the key is to figure out
how to put it into a tree.
So I'm not going to draw the
picture because it gets too
complicated,
but basically what you want to
know is how valuable--
remember the tree in backward
induction?
It was, take the thing at the
end and then figure out by
propagating the values
backwards.
So if I have black and red
here, and I've got 1 black card
and no red cards,
the value to me of that is
what?
I'm going to win 1 dollar for
sure.
If there's only 1 black card
left in the deck and no red
cards I know I'm going to play
to the end and get 1 dollar,
and obviously the value of 2
black cards and no red cards is
2 dollars etcetera.
And I also know,
what's the value to me of no
black cards?
You know at every stage what's
left in the deck because you've
seen what came up before.
So if you're at the very end of
the deck with no black cards and
1 red card what's the value of
that position to you?
Student: 0.
Prof: 0,
not minus 1,0,
why is that?
Because you're going to quit,
you're not going to play and
that's the critical step,
seeing that this is 0.
Someone said minus 1.
That difference between 0 and
minus 1, that's the whole heart
of the thing.
So 0 and 2, the value of that
is also 0.
You're just going to quit.
So what in general is the value?
What is the value of V if there
are B black cards and R red
cards what's the value to you?
Well, a crucial step is that
you can choose to quit by not
playing.
So this is the value from then
on to you.
So B black cards left,
R red cards left.
You could get 0 by quitting,
or you could draw a card.
Now, what happens to you if you
draw a card?
What happens to you if you draw
a card?
Well, with probability B over
(B R) you win 1 dollar,
right, but then you move on to
the new deck.
So what do I write V here,
V of B - 1 and R,
but with probability R over (B
R), you drew a red card,
so that's minus 1,
but then you move onto a deck
that has 1 less red card,
and that's it.
You either decide to stop or if
you've decided to draw a card
you know what the chances of
getting a black card are.
You look at the black cards, 26.
I'm down there.
It's 21 out of 47.
It sounds horrible,
21 out of 47,
I win 1 dollar.
26 out of 47 I lose 1 dollar.
So the immediate draw is
terrible, but if I get a black
card I move to this situation,
and if I get a red card I move
to this situation.
So do you agree with me that
that's what the value's going to
be?
Are there any questions?
This is a critical formula,
a critical spot.
Does everyone--Sophia you're
now in trouble.
Somebody came and said hello to
me after class and now I know a
name, so does this formula make
sense?
Student: Yes.
Prof: Kathleen, yes?
Is it Katherine or Kathleen?
Student: Katherine.
Prof: Katherine, okay.
Katherine, so you agree with
this formula,
right?
But this formula's the key.
It's just like our tree.
Once you know what the values
are down here you can always go
backwards and figure out the
value here.
So what is the tree?
The tree is going to
have--well, I'm going I'm going
to do it on a computer.
So now we can just do this on a
computer.
I hope I don't have to do that.
So you have this,
by the way, it's on the web.
Oh no!
Why are all these,
oh okay, there aren't question
marks.
So here it is.
So you can see that on this,
I can do it with this,
on this thing it's--by the way,
I did my own spreadsheet and an
undergraduate last year thought
it was so messy that she just
redid it for me.
So this is her doing.
It looks much better than I did.
So anyway, here are the number
of cards.
This is what the number of
black cards left.
This is the number of red cards
left,
and then when you go to the
corresponding coordinate like
this one,
this is the value of the game
when you have 1 black card and 1
red card.
Even though there's an even
deck it's a favorable game to
you.
Why is that?
Because you draw the first
card, if it's black,
which happens with probability
50 percent, you win 1 dollar.
So you've got half a dollar.
If it's red,
which happens with 50 percent
probability, you draw the next
one and so you end up with 0.
And by the way,
if you got a black the first
time, obviously you stop.
So you get 50 percent chance of
1 dollar and stopping or 50
percent chance of going to the
end and getting nothing,
so it's value of 50 percent,
but that's a bad way of
calculating that number.
She's got a much better way of
calculating it.
So what she said is if you had
no red cards and only black
cards the value is to go to the
end of the deck and just win
them all.
So if you've got only red cards
in the deck and the top line is
no black cards obviously you
should quit right away.
So we've got this first thing
trivially done.
Now, how do you figure out this
thing?
Well, if you look at the
formula up there it's just the
formula you wrote,
we wrote, which is you could
quit if you wanted to.
So you have to take the max of
0, but if you go on and draw,
I can't read what's written
there, if you go on and draw
there's going to be the
probability of red,
this is the probability of
getting a red over the total
number of cards times losing 1
dollar,
plus what happens is you then
move.
If you drew red then you go
to--what did she do?
Student:
>
the value.
Prof: C 4,
oh C 4 is here,
right.
So sorry, I was getting
confused with the cards.
So C 4 is this squared.
That's the value in here.
So C 4 says if you draw a red
card the first time,
it happens with this
probability, the number of reds
over the total number of cards,
you lose 1 dollar and then you
move to the position C 4,
which is 1 back here,
the one where you've got 1 less
red card and just a black card
left.
On the other hand,
you could have drawn the first
time,
not the red one but the black
one divided by the total number
of cards,
and you would have won 1
dollar, but then you would have
moved to the position where you
had 1 less black card,
which is D 3, which is up here.
So instead of doing the whole
game, she says,
half the time you win,
but then you move over to here
and get that value.
Half the time you lose,
and then you lose 1 dollar,
and then you move over to here.
So she's done that.
That same formula appears in
every box, so all you had to do
was just copy it.
It's max of 0,
and then the chance that you're
going to lose 1 dollar,
which is the number here of
reds over the totals times minus
1 dollar and then moving over to
here.
Or you could get the
probability of winning 1 dollar
with the black cards.
So you win 1 dollar,
but then you move up to here.
So it's very simple.
So she's done it.
And notice that although the
deck is even at 1 card each,
so it sounds like a fair game,
it's not.
It's a favorable game because
you have an option,
so you all understood that,
but the thing is the option is
much more valuable than you
think.
So let's see what the value of
the game is.
It's when you had 26 black
cards and 26 red cards,
so we have to go way over to
here.
Sorry.
Where am I going?
That's not the right answer.
Here it is, 26,26,
the value of the game is 2.6
dollars, not just half a dollar.
You wanted to quit,
wherever you are,
at half a dollar.
He's not looking up anymore.
So he wanted to quit after the
first draw, but it's much better
than that.
So now what the shocking thing,
though, is, so this means with
26,26 you have a favorable game
and you should draw.
If you didn't draw it'd be
worth 0.
So obviously you're supposed to
draw here.
If you get a black card you're
going to go here.
So here you're down.
You've gotten a card and you've
got one more,
you know, it wasn't that likely
you were going to get black,
but if you did--50 percent
chance you go here.
So you win 1 dollar and now
you're at this position.
Now, if you're supposed to stop
at that point,
what would you have done?
If you were supposed to stop at
that point you would have had
value 0.
So the fact that that number is
positive is telling you even
when the deck is against you,
25, you can't see it,
it's 25 blacks and still 26
reds it's still a favorable
game.
You should draw a card and if
by some miracle you won 1 dollar
you would have moved to here.
So now you're 26 red and 24
black, but the game is still
favorable.
You should draw another card,
and if you win again you're
here.
Now you've gone one,
two, three times you've drawn
blacks.
You should still draw another
one.
Four times getting blacks you
should still draw another one.
Five consecutive black draws
the deck is now 26 against you
and 21 in your favor.
You should draw again.
The game is still slightly
favorable, and it just seems
shocking that could be the case,
but this is the proof that it's
the case.
So anyway, that illustrates the
power of the option of being
able to continue.
And if you work,
you're going to work out low
numbers 2 and 3 in the homework,
and then you'll see very
clearly why it is that this
option is just so powerful.
It's uncannily strong.
So are there any questions
about this?
Yes?
Student: I'm still a
little bit confused.
I know that the option value is
positive, but the probability
actually is a little bit against
you.
So especially after five wins
why do you want another draw,
because yes,
the option value is a little
bit positive,
but the probability is still
against you?
Prof: This isn't the
option value.
This is the value of playing.
So it says the option value is
more important than the fact
that the cards are against you.
So he's asking,
my TA is asking,
how could it possibly be that
the deck is now 26 red and 21
black totally against you and
according to this calculation
you should still draw?
He can't see the advantage in
drawing because the odds are
pretty high you're going to get
a red card next time.
Well, that's true.
You're going to get a red card
next time, but the thing is your
downside is limited.
Here's a way of thinking about
it.
You're up 5 cards.
You can never lose more than 5
dollars from that point on
because you can always play to
the end of the deck,
right, which means you lose the
five back that you already won.
So there's a downside--the
downside of losing is limited
here.
On the other hand there's a big
upside to you.
You might by some miracle draw
10 consecutive black ones at
that point and then you could
quit.
So your upside is much bigger
than your downside.
Now, the upside is less
probable than the downside so
it's not so obvious which is
going to be bigger.
Is the option value more
important or is the fact that
the deck is against you more
important?
It would be impossible to
intuit the answer,
but we don't have to intuit it.
We just proved it.
We solved for the optimal
strategy.
Are there any other questions?
It's quite amazing,
right, this--I'm going to pause
for a second.
Yes?
Student: How do you
calculate the profit at a given
position?
Prof: That's what we
just did.
So let's try it again.
Student: It may not be a
total profit.
Prof: So what we did,
this number V is the expected
profit you're going to make if
you start with B black cards and
R red cards.
And now the intuitive mind
figures that if B is less than R
you've got an unfavorable deck
and you should just quit,
but that's not the case.
You can figure out what the
profit is, how,
by doing backward induction.
You couldn't tell what the
value of this bond is here with
all these defaults and stuff
until you started computing
backwards until you got to here,
so the same way here.
We know at the edges it's very
obvious when all the cards are
black or all the cards are red,
that's up here,
it's obvious what the value is.
But if you have a position here
you can figure out what the
value is of being in that
position of 1 and 1.
You could quit and be 0,
or you could say,
what are my chances of getting
a black card and winning 1
dollar?
If I get a black card then I
move to this position,
but I already figured out this
position's value because I'm
doing backward induction,
right?
That's got one less--sorry,
if I draw a black card I go
this way.
It's got 1 less black card and
we already know that value of
that position is 0.
So to figure out the value of
this position I know the chance
of getting a black card,
then I'm going to end up in
that position which is value 0.
I won't draw any more.
Or I'm going to get a red card
and then I'm going to move to
this position over here whose
value I've already computed.
So that gives me the value here.
How do I figure out the value
here?
Well, it's now 2 reds and 1
black.
So this looks really bad.
Actually this position,
the value of this I happen to
know is 0.
How could it be,
with 2 red cards and only 1
black card actually the value of
the position is 0?
Well, what do I do?
The chances of getting a black
card the first time are 1 third.
So V of (1,2) is going to be 1
third of getting a black card
plus then I go to here which is
no black cards left and just red
cards,
which obviously is 0,
plus 2 thirds.
2 thirds of the time I get a
red card and lose 1 dollar,
but then I'm going to move to
here with 1 red card where I
have V of (1 and 1),
which I've already figured out
the answer to,
right?
This was V of (1 and 1) has
value a half.
So therefore V of (1 and 2) is
going to be 2 thirds times minus
1 V of (1,2),
right?
I just drew a black card so
it's no longer--no,
I drew a red card,
so it's (1 and 1).
So I started with 1 black and 2
reds,
1 third of the time I get a
black card,
2 thirds of the times I get a
red card,
but after getting the red card
the position is now 1 black and
1 red.
The red card disappeared.
That's over here.
So I get a black card,
I move to here.
If I get a red card I move to
there,
but V of (1,1) is worth a half,
so that's equal to 1 third
times (1 0) 2 thirds times
(minus 1 1 half),
which equals 1 third - 1 third
which equals 0.
So starting at this point
you've got 1 red card and 2
black cards.
It looks horrible to pick a
card, 2 thirds of the time
you're going to get the wrong
card,
but you still have a position
that's actually equal in value,
because if you get that black
card which wins you stop.
If you get a red card you're
now in a position that's equal
deck and that's favorable for
you,
because if you get another
black card you stop,
and if you get a red card you
keep playing until the end.
So that's it.
So how can you do this by
backward induction?
You have the stuff on the edges
and then you solve for all these
things along the side here,
and having done that now I can
solve for this one because I've
got up and to the left.
Now I do that row and then I
can do this whole row,
and then I can just by backward
induction do the whole thing,
and the computer does that
instantly.
So it figures out the value of
every single node and it's
shocking what the answer is.
So are there any other
questions about this?
Ben, do you-- so...
Student: Yeah,
I figured it out.
I tell you initially I'm
thinking about it.
Well, maybe this value is
actually an option value.
For example if you choose to
play this game and after you win
or you lose then you'll get an
option to continue the game,
and so I separated that option
value to this.
Prof: Well,
that is your option.
The option is always to keep
playing or to stop,
but the value I wrote down is
the value of the game to you,
of being able to play the whole
game however you want.
So now let's do another example.
Yes?
Student: Would you call
somebody rational who doesn't
play the game up to that point
that you showed me,
the point .05
>
Prof: Right,
so if you got...
Student: My question is,
is it preference to risk or is
it actually the rationality
of...
Prof: Right,
so this is going to become very
important very shortly.
So his question is I just
proved if you can call that a
proof by computer,
the computer proved that even
if you got 5 blacks in a row you
should still draw another card.
Of course things are quite
risky now because there's a very
good chance you're going to lose
on that very next card.
So he's saying if you're risk
averse maybe you would stop
there,
and how can you distinguish
somebody who's risk averse from
somebody who's just dumb and
can't make the calculation.
So that's going to be a
question we're going to take up
in the very next class.
But I would say that it's
usually because people are dumb
and can't make the calculation.
So they just don't realize how
favorable the situation is
they're in by having this option
to be able to play to the end,
to stop when they want to stop.
So let's just do one more
example.
Suppose that you are
undergraduates and you want to
get married.
You've been told that's a good
idea,
and you--it's going to be a
very sexist thing,
but anyway this is also a game
I invented which turned out not
to be as original as I thought.
So I call this the optimal
marriage problem.
So let's say you knew you were
going to meet 1,000 women.
You're telling it from the
guy's point of view.
You're going to meet 1,000
women and each woman you meet
her suitability you can't tell
until you meet her and talk to
her,
and after you meet her each
woman's suitability is uniformly
distributed on (0,1).
So what do I mean by that?
I mean you meet her,
you talk to her,
you get to know her,
and before you met her,
you have no idea how suitable
she's going to be.
After you've talked to her you
understand how suitable.
The best, it's 1.
The worst, it's 0,
and it could be a draw anywhere
between 0 and 1.
Before you meet her you have no
idea.
After you meet her you know
exactly how suitable she is,
and there are going to be 1,000
of them that you could meet.
The problem is that after
you've talked to a woman you can
marry her then,
or you can move on,
but once you've moved on you
can never go back to her.
So you understand the problem.
The problem is that let's say
the first woman is .95 or .90.
You think, gosh how suitable.
This is a great match,
but I've got 999 more women to
go.
Maybe I'll do better,
and then you get 0s from then
on,
and so you've missed your .90,
and so you're going to end up
marrying the last one who's
maybe a 0 for you.
That doesn't mean she's a 0,
just for you a 0.
I'm trying.
Anyway, so what should your
optimal strategy be and are you
playing the optimal strategy.
So what do you think,
just intuitively,
what's the optimal strategy?
Of course we're going to do it
by backward induction,
but what do you think it's
going to look like,
the optimal strategy?
Yes?
Student: The further you
get into the game the less
selective you should be.
Prof: Right,
that's what's going to happen.
We're going to prove this,
but he's exactly picked--he
said, you set a threshold here
at the beginning.
You'll marry her if she's above
some number.
You keep to that threshold for
a while.
Then you haven't married anyone
and you'd say,
oh my god, I'm running out of
women and then your standards
just collapse.
Desperation sets in.
So that's absolutely right,
but the only interesting thing
is to figure out how high the
standard should be.
So how high do you think it is
at the beginning?
What would you say the number
is at the beginning?
Now, let me give you a hint.
If you divide up--here's 1 and
there's 1,000 women,
so here's 0.
So they're randomly picked.
So if you could look at all the
women, and pick out the most
suitable one,
what would her suitability be?
Well, her suitability would
be--so top, the top on average
will be something like 1,000
over 1,001.
This is a famous problem.
If you take N people randomly,
you take N numbers you pick
randomly uniformly on (0,
1) the top one on average is
going to be,
if there's 1,000 women it's
1,000 over 1,001.
Second top is going to be 999
over 1,001.
So this very standard
statistical result actually was
derived by a former Yale
professor in World War II.
The Americans captured German
tanks which had all their serial
numbers on them.
The first tank was number 1,
the second tank was number 2,
the third tank they made was
number 3,
so we captured a bunch of them
and then we had to guess,
how many tanks did they make?
Anyhow, so it's related to this
idea that if they're uniformly
distributed on (0,
1) the top one's going to be on
average 1,000 over 1,001,
999 over 1,001 etcetera.
So what standard would you set
for the first one?
Right?
You have to set some threshold
here.
Here's one and here's 0.
By the end you'll take the last
woman you've got--you're going
to take her no matter what.
So what should the threshold be?
Well, it's hard to tell.
We can't do it except by
backward induction.
So what would you guess?
Student: 1
>
Prof: 1,
well then you'll never take her
if it's 1 because the odds of
getting exactly 1 are 0,
so what would you guess?
Student:
>
Prof: So you'd set the
threshold this high,
1,000 over 1,001.
So that means you're expecting
to get as good a woman as if you
could go to the very end and
look at all of them,
you never make a mistake.
I told you, there's a chance
you'll make a mistake.
The first one's the best.
It doesn't quite come to your
threshold and all the rest are
worse then you end up with a
disaster here.
So you have a chance of not
doing that well,
so you're setting too high a
standard here,
because you have a very good
chance of saying no to all these
women and then ending up with
what's--
right?
However, you're on the right
track.
So amazingly,
this is the answer,
this is the threshold.
So you should set the threshold
at where you expect the second
highest woman to be,
the second highest match to be,
and that is why there's so many
novels about the other woman
because if you're playing
optimally you should be ending
up with the second best woman
and there should be one other
woman that at the end of your
life you regret that you didn't
wait for,
but only one other woman.
So anyway, I just want to prove
this to you in the same way we
proved it before just by solving
for backward induction for the
optimal--
so we can just do this by
backward induction.
We know exactly what to do.
It's one thing to say what you
should do.
It's another thing to prove
that's what you should do and
I'm going to prove it now.
So you can just see by backward
induction how easy it is to do
these things.
I'm going to have to take four
minutes.
If you can hang out for four
minutes we'll get this.
So what happens with 2 women
left?
What's V of 2?
What should you do?
What should your threshold be
for 2 women?
So here's the threshold.
Threshold for 1 woman is 0.
If it's the last woman there
whatever she is that's it.
You might as well marry her.
It can't be negative.
And then the value--unlike
Herodotus--
the value of 1 is going to be a
half,
right, because if there's 1
woman left you're going to take
her no matter what and on
average you'll get a half.
So the question is now,
what's the threshold when there
are 2 women left and what's your
expected payoff?
So what's the threshold if
there are 2 women left?
You see the second to last
woman, you talk to her,
you find out how good the match
is.
You should take her if the
match is above what?
Student: 1 over 1,001?
Prof: No,
there's only 1 woman left after
her, so.
So a half, right,
because if you don't take her
you're going to go to the last
woman and on an average you're
going to get a half,
so there's no point in taking
someone whose match is less than
a half when the very next step
you're,
on average, you're going to get
a half.
So your threshold is a half.
So what's your expected quality
of the match?
Well, with probability a half
she's going to be above a half,
and if she's above a half she's
going to be half way between 1
and a half,
so it's 3 quarters.
And with probability,
sorry, and with probability a
half she's going to be below a
half and you're going to pass on
her and go to the last one and
it'll be on average a half.
So this is 3 eighths plus, no.
Probability a half,
she's going to be 3 quarters
and probability a half,
she'll be a half so it's 3
eighths 1 quarter,
is 5 eights.
Now, what if there are 3 women,
what should the threshold be
for 3 women and what's the value
of 3?
Student: 5 eighths.
Prof: So the threshold
should be V of 2,
which is 5 eighths,
and what's the value?
The value's going to be,
what's the chance that you take
the one you just meet?
Well, the odds that she's above
a half [correction:
above V(2)]
is 3 eighths,
so it's 3 eighths times the
average of 1,
you know, half way between,
so he's above 5 eights,
so she's somewhere between 1
and 5 eighths.
So that's going to be (1 5
eighths) over 2,
plus 5 eighths of the time you
pass on her and then you get 5
eighths.
So that equals,
if we just do that a little bit
more generally,
it's 1 - V (2)--So that's (1 -
V (2)) times (1 V (2)) divided
by 2 V (2) times V (2).
So that's the formula.
So in general V (t),
you set the threshold at V
-(t-1).
So with probability V (t-1)
you're going to get (1 V (t-1))
divided by 2,
and with probability 1 minus,
no.
This is 1 - V (t-1),
with probability of V (t-1)
you're going to get--you're
going to pass on her and go to
the next thing so you get just V
(t-1).
So that's just a formula.
V(t) equals some function of
V(t-1).
So you can program that into a
computer.
So I'm ending now with this one
picture.
That's the end of it.
Sorry.
I know I've gone over,
but this is the last picture.
It'll only take a second.
So 0, yield curve optimal
marriage, so here it is,
with one woman your value--oh
shit, sorry.
With 1 woman the value is a
half, 1 match to go.
So the number on the left is
with 1 match to go the value's a
half, with 2 it's 5 eighths,
with 3 we computed that too.
So you can tell for however
many women you want.
Now, what I've done on the
right number,
is this N - 1 over N 1.
So that's the second best woman
how good she'd be on average for
you,
and as you go down further and
further you see these numbers
are getting to be the same.
So this number and this
number's practically the same
and if you go down to the very
bottom you'll see they're
identical.
Up to an incredible number of
decimal places these two numbers
are the same.
So if there are enough women
you're going to get exactly the
second best, and it's going to
be the problem of the other
woman.
But anyway, the point of all
this was to just illustrate how
powerful the option is.
It's as if you could go to the
very end and pick out the second
best one even though you have to
do them sequentially,
so.